Using formal terminology, regular expressions describe regular languages.
Remember that officially a language is a set of strings.
These grammars that we've been introducing describe something new--
context-free languages.
For now, context free just means that if you have a rule
A can be replaces by B in your grammar and you have an A,
you can replace it with a B regardless of what this nearby context is
as long as you hold the context the same.
If I can use the rule now, I can also use it if there's no x on one side,
no z on the other, if there's nothing on the left, if there's nothing on the right,
if there are flying monkeys on the left and flying monkeys on the right
regardless of the context I can apply this rule.
The set of languages that can be described by re-write rules or grammers like this
are called "context-free languages."
All the formal grammars we are going over describe context-free languages--
a more powerful set of string than our old friends the regular languages.
Here I've drawn a little chart showing three different regular expression forms
and the corresponding context-free grammar forms on the right.
If you had a regular expression concatenation--
regular expression a followed by regular expression b--
we could build a grammar than did the same thing
just by putting a and b next to each other on the right-hand side.
If you had a star--regular expression a*--we could do the same thing--
the same effect of having zero or more a's--with two rules.
Either we have nothing or we have an a followed by zero or more a's.
Finally, here we have regular expression disjunction or choice--either a or b--
that's easy to write with two separate grammar rules.
G goes to a or g goes to b.
For all three of these cases and regular expressions there is something
corresponding we can do in the world of context-free grammars.
Now, I haven't shown you how to do something like a+,
but remember that a+ is just a a*.
I've already shown you how to do concatenation and the star.
In theory, you could compose it over here as well.
At this point it might seem like regular expressions and context-free grammars
are equal, but they are not.